Casper kadian Muller had everything
working against him he could have quit
when the pandemic destroyed his team
Trump just won't be paying the cinnamon
though let's be real he could have given
up when his peers accused him of
cheating we don't want our names to be
framed for the rest of our lives instead
Katie and taught everyone else a lesson
you're never done if you don't give up
he tries to snap over gets hit by device
who runs out and dies 1v3 from Canadian
also they're rapping him far faster than
he's ready for who's now he's gonna
finish the job oh Canadian and twists
wants to rip them from their fingertips
down in with the up and now rubs his
death
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Global Offensive Canadian should have
been in the right place at the right
time he cut his teeth on CS Source in
Denmark one of the game's most
competitive and dominant regions but
Canadian's bad luck began when he
started to realize that his unique
combination of both in-game leading and
opting could be difficult to fit into
every roster for two of the first teams
that I played on it definitely also
compromised a lot with like
um my role right I I was always the igl
and the awp and in these two teams like
at Mouse cliche was oppa and an SK
freest was the override despite
qualifying for three out of the first
four CS go majors kadian and his
teammates weren't able to do any real
damage at the events themselves it is
absolutely nervous he's gotten tagged up
by Kucha then but oh my God he did find
a trend but Kucha swiftly shut down that
threat and we will be seeing Hellraisers
going on Canadian spent much of 2015
with SK gaming and the first half half
of 2016 with Team preparation but
neither team qualified for much or
helped develop his resume during this
stretch he did get some opportunities on
the analyst desk at events and he was
actually pretty good at it but kadian
didn't want to talk about Champions his
dream was still the Hoist trophies so he
did something drastic he went to North
America he stood in for twists on TSM
who was ineligible to appear on Ely due
to his age and played alongside sick
automatic FNS and sent this and while no
one gave TSM much of a chance many Saw
kadian as a positive addition how will
the timing work out here as he goes for
the peak he can't get his census is
gonna secure the frag and in doing so
the 1611 map 2 goes to TSM an unlikely
result then his own roster was picked up
by Rogue in August and retooled to
include Bulgarian players bubble and
Victor in October just under three
months later Rogue cracked the hltv top
30 with a win at esea season 23 over
ldlc it was Mountain Dew League sure but
this team had improved and kadian was
forced to balance the leadership demands
of some very different players well it
had a small culture class back then
because the bulgarians were used to spy
leaders so they were like why are you
not yelling at me like they were like
and and then they had two Danes in the
team they wanted to get yelled at and we
didn't want it you know like okay
explain it to me call me please don't
yell at me so like I was like this
complete complete culture Clash after
the Rogue roster wound down from player
departures they kept him in mind when a
twist of fate gave him an opening Cadian
pounced even though it meant playing in
N A there was some what else though I
don't know if you remembered he said
probably he signed from Ghost to that's
right I remember this and then like 20
hours before the deadline he was like
nah not anyways and then he went back to
ghost or something so they needed one
and they called me and I told myself
I'll go there for three months make some
uh make some money make some money yeah
make them survive in the pro league
because they were like at the
relegations but they were like dead last
or second last and I got there and we
just developed a really good project
quickly kadian spent a lot more than
three months in North America in fact it
was a full year and Roe gave him
valuable experience leading a developing
Squad that truly bought into his system
and his work ethic most importantly the
team finally brought him back to the
major Vice coming in there is a timer to
this and there is the backstab Android's
gone now Shazam has to look into two
places and he can't 16 to 11 Rogue have
done it and you can see how much it
means to kadian and though he won a
series against space soldiers kadian's
run was again stopped short in part by
Danes coming in from bonano Scott's
effects to play against can he win the
battle no not quite zip X finishes him
up through the wall now down to Cadian
that's a stunning shot there from Kaden
onto device but that's all he's able to
do an astralis grind it out but making
it to the major was enough for some
teams to take notice of cadian's
continued grind in the usual chaos of
the postmate major Shuffle so he finally
got another chance his hard work paid
off he finally went home
Denmark could seize their second major
win seemingly putting astralis on track
to continue an era of unparalleled
dominance but kadian was still working
on a win now with North one of the
country's top teams kadian was able to
both op and Lead which helped his team
rise as high as 7th ranked on hltv
during his eight-month tenure but land
results were elusive kadian later told
hltv in an interview that he saw the
Spirit of mutual sacrifice he expected
from his roster fate and he knew that
his days were numbered if one guy
doesn't want to sacrifice because he
sees this team potentially as
um a stepping stone for the next bigger
team or whatever you see him he doesn't
want to run in okay well hell no I'm not
gonna run in for this guy then if he's
not ever gonna do it for me why would I
run for him and those kind of mentality
just really fits us in that team I think
after six months on the bench with North
his shot finally came heroics blame F
departed for complexity and Cadian slid
onto the roster but not as igl Snappy
assumed leadership duties while kadian
played primary op he took to the role
with gusto putting up some solid
performances no smoke on the coffins
lots of damage inflicted and they're
gonna be walking in
to a bit of a truck that's the talk with
the Famas from the side is spraying them
down from CT
Tavern has been caught leaving Dennis
alone they know where he is and Canadian
will not miss out on his chance three
kills goes to the offer and for five
months heroic picked up steam is left
just on to stierson and faving to try
and hold on and faven he's actually
managed to catch him with the awp in
Middle switching over to the right we're
trying to clear the pit but he fails
it's left onto season to try and save
them in the Grand Final and he's not
gonna do it it will be heroic with the
victory style you'll be right through
the Facebook
um
well he's had some very nice
performances today this might be just
too much ribs down ready and waiting for
an aggressive up close and burstful in
his face
ump comes out but it's gonna do
absolutely nothing heroic are your GG
bet winter Cup winners 2020 and they do
it in style without dropping a single
map across any series heroic was firing
on all cylinders and fun Plus Phoenix
bought the roster out in time for season
one a Flashpoint but at the last second
the deal fell through we as fpx
heroic call us whatever name you want
we'll not be finishing the first group
stage of flashband
probably just won't be playing the
cinnamon though let's be real cadian's
desperation his raw emotions were
entirely understandable his Road had
been long enough he had experienced
plenty of bad luck but this was
different still there was only one thing
to do chart a new course and work twice
as hard to get back to the top heroic
hired long-time Danish igl hundon as
their coach adding a wealth of
information on potential opponents as
well as helping to build a structural
frame for cadian's looser igl style so
that's how we started the team and I was
like this is not going to do well we're
not going to be a top five team if we
don't have some kind of a structure so
we try to create some kind of a
structured freedom-ish thing on the T
side so people could do whatever they
wanted to do but in a controlled way
where everyone knew how how they were
going to react heroic wanted to make
their Mark and at cologne they showed
exactly how far they had come now you
can be very quick behind them they're
going up hey and Katie if that smoker
rise I think they're gonna disrespect it
he's got a good chance at another here
Canadian's on for four maybe even the
A's gone Cadian he takes over the game
next is in this one Nico with a double
he's got to line him up again oh the
reload and now the 1v1 he needs the ace
to keep this safe he does it Nico the
timing could not be better for him again
oh no the Lion's Den
quad kill for Grand Final point for the
trophy
[Music]
and they're the last team standing
unbelievable with a 150 000 grand prize
and a win over Vitality Katie and proved
that he had what it took to bring his
style of IG yelling and opting to the
very top of the Counter-Strike world but
the celebration was cut short just a few
days later when hundon was implicated in
a wide-reaching cheating scandal
involving the use of a spectator buff
I've got this game loaded up it's heroic
versus astralis it's the match where
hundin for the first 10 Rounds had a
coach camera or had a camera and free
cam on banana almost immediately the
accusations came how could Cadian not
have known the news cast out on all of
heroic but especially their leader but
kadian was undeterred he told everyone
that he hadn't cheated and that the
team's number one rank was the result of
hard work so basically we have 96 uh
apps played in the past three months
yeah we participate dissipated in
literally everything that we possibly
could then they took dreamhack open fall
without their now banned coach
reaffirming their status as one of the
best teams in the world five vs 3 for
Heroic to close this tournament to win
yet another online event to cement
themselves at the top of Counter-Strike
shocks trying his damnedest Apex with
only 14 HP 1v3 and get ready for Acadian
pop-off cause he's stunning he closes
and leads his team to yet another win
the end of the year was less kind to
heroic though and changes had to be made
he's looking around Jesus mine but no
Cheryl takes the fight takes the win
16-3 heroic full Nico and borup were
benched in February and the team brought
in refresh and shush exciting players
with sky-high potential but kadian
didn't talk about their one Taps he
talked about their determination and
drive they're working very hard and
there's no complaining if you ask them
to do something they'll do it straight
away and that's part of the profile with
them that's why we chose them as well
they have undeniable Talent we know that
but Talon can only drive you so far you
need to be willing to put in the hours
and these two will so yeah picking those
two you can already feel at this point
was the right decision the new squad's
first Big Challenge ESL Pro League
season 13 where the best teams in the
world waited to see how much damage this
new look heroic could do that's the op
and kills the guy CT I yeah ah yeah oh
oh my God he's knifed him and he's
gotten away with the orb I'm starting to
get nervous
there's no way there's no way Katie you
can't win pro league like this you can't
win pro league like this no way
access left 40 seconds and the bombs on
a take your time son you're about to
make the play of your career guess the
info he just has to hit this shot and
he's done it for Heroic the leader
calling well above his years clearing Oh
no you're an animal heroic I've done it
and I just can't believe it Cadian
pulled off one of the greatest ever
clutches in CS history locking in his
reputation as one of the greatest igls
not only in Denmark but the world
heading into IEM cologne 2021 kadian
wasn't just confident against astralis
he felt like his team's recent results
spoke for themselves astralis hasn't had
any rivalry with any other team because
they've always won
and I'll be quite Frank but at this
point we haven't lost to them for a very
long time so if they beat us today I can
accept the fact that we have a rivalry
but if we don't I'll smash the hammer
and say there's no nothing and the kings
of Denmark sit happily on their Throne
there it is they're after the playoffs
astralis logged in clearly there was
more to be done but while kadian was
working on that more controversy racked
the organization Hunden was reinstated
in April 2021 and then released in July
when heroic began legal proceedings
against him where they alleged that he
had shared sensitive strategic
information with the competitor then in
August Hunden claimed that the heroic
players knew about his use of The
Spectator bug that earned him his
initial ban he followed that up in
September with proof of a conversation
between himself and Nico a former member
of the team the Esports Integrity
commission cleared everyone on a heroic
except Nico and heroic shared their
emotionally charged side of the story in
September we want this story out we want
the community to understand
because I think as you have seen earlier
in this video
it's not been easy to be under this kind
of pressure from co-players and co-co
colleagues in in the industry so
we don't want our names to be framed for
the rest of our lives moving past
hunting was critical because the team
needed to be focused for their next goal
the Stockholm major the first since Lan
events returned
triple kill for tessas he is going to
try and play a close legendary angle
here top of banana there's the first
Kill from Katie and gets the second as
well not gonna get the third though so
close but he's done his job this round
they might be in a lot of trouble G2
have the problem side on lockdown shush
with a big double but hunter he's back
for more and now he just has to stay
alive still Katie and left and they get
eradicated by Hunter it's 19 to 15 G2
make the grand finals of the major a
narrow OT loss to G2 couldn't have felt
good but this heroic roster had grown
immensely since 2020. in 2022 heroic's
identity continued to develop under
Canadian as well as the team's new coach
former pro player exist they weren't the
most structured team but they worked
hard had incredible clutch potential and
they weren't afraid to get loud I'm
still like yelling at my teammates right
like even in practice you can put us in
practice against the top 45 team in the
world and we're making some stupid
mistakes so we literally just talked
about from reviewing one of our games at
Dharma I'm gonna tell people when it's
not good enough a top four finisher
katowice was more valuable experience
for the roster the results at the next
major in Antwerp slipped slightly but
each tournament gave the team new data
and New Opportunities when they were
forced to replace refresh with yabby
halfway through the year there was an
adjustment period but again when it was
time for the real major heroic showed up
30 seconds on the clock not a whole lot
of time if you want to transfer between
the ball sites this is everything this
engagement is huge from stout oh and
yeah one on one it's just cyber left on
the other side once again to try and
save it
nice Flash doesn't catch down and he's
going to have a little love of brags in
the round there they come three and four
and it's all five with every passing
second of that bomb The Outsiders
prepare to start a new celebration and
while winning the major is always the
goal that doesn't mean you can't
appreciate some of the other victories
too especially when it's at home now
acadian's the next one finds an initial
they're rapping him far faster than he's
ready for still he's gonna finish the
job
oh Canadian we get to walk back around
the cat replacing the dead body of props
looking for the impact but it's heroic
into the kill feed
with two rounds on a t side in the OT
the pressure is so real the dreams are
alive and twists wants to rip them from
their fingertips down in with the up and
now robs
with his win at the event Canadian's
roster ended the year at the very top of
the hltv rankings but maybe more
importantly kadian was where he belonged
bye
man
he didn't give up during his major
drought when he might have had the
option to move to working on the desk at
events he didn't give up when he played
in North America or when his team
collapsed around him he didn't give up
when events went online and even the
best players in the world struggled to
give a hundred percent Cadian isn't a
generation defining aimer he isn't a
highlight machine but after a decade
spent grinding his way to the top he
showed us that natural Talent isn't
everything and standing on that stage
tearfully embracing his mom kadian
taught all of us that hard work can
always take you to the top
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for a unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock